يوجد متجر رامين في جزيرة روجيري
قبالة الطرف الشمالي لليابان للوصول إلى
هناك من طوكيو لمدة ساعتين إلى
سابورو ثم استقل القطار إلى
أكاني ، أقصى مدينة في شمال اليابان ،
ثم استقل العبارة للوصول إلى جزيرة ري في
طريقك إلى الغرب  جزء
من الجزيرة وبمجرد وصولك إلى هناك
، فلنأمل أن تكون في الوقت المحدد مفتوحًا فقط
ساعتين ونصف الساعة في اليوم ، لكن
الرحلة تستحق العناء لأن المكان يقال إنه
يحتوي على بعض من أفضل رامين في كل
اليابان عندما  يتعلق الأمر برامين في اليابان ،
فهناك عدد قليل من الأماكن التي
تجذب أسماؤها أشخاصًا من جميع أنحاء العالم ، يعد
رامين ميروكو أحد هذه الأماكن ،
ويأتي الزوار للحصول على
رامين الصويا هذا المصنوع من مرق الأعشاب البحرية كومبو المحلي ،
كاكاكو ماساتو يوما ، يا واتاشي
وا أكل  حتى داميانو ميرا ،
تظل المدينة مجرد متطرف مع
نانانا ، آسف يا رجل أمانو تسشيدا إيتشي يظل مجهولاً ، لا
، لا يمكنهم Emoto no basilican يفعل أي SEO
أو رجالنا إلى yukata Today Show ضد
عدو جديد neshama ثاني مشؤوم لنا
طبيب المال تاباثا كوليت كايوس
مصطفى وهذا ليس رامين فوريًا ، مما يجعل
الطبق يستغرق ساعات
من مقصفنا الضخم كانام لا يوجد
خطأ أمني في المدرسة الفرعية مع شيفا
ينقل في البداية ناروتو في كل
حالة دولفت وليس المخرج سوبردوج
نيتشيرين شو أوما يأكل حتى ربطة عنق
تشيكا المقدسة  chicka Rito ، هذا هو
اختيارك ، يجب أن تحرص على أن
يحذر دعم ساعات العمل العليا في الثمانينيات
أغاسي لأن المنسق فقط يظهر أنك تعرف
الممر الفائق قطاعنا وهو ماساتو
تسوباسا / ملحمة باريس تمامًا في
وحداتنا تثير الفوضى ، بالطبع ،
لماذا تعتقد أن الناس يأتون  بهذه الطريقة ،
تخيل أن Negreanu jaymota تعرف أنها
تتدخل في بيانات Danica دون البحث
عن البيانات بشكل عام ، فهي دائمًا ما يكون دورنا
واحدًا من رامين متفحم ، يرجى من هؤلاء جميعًا
مشاركة ذلك لأنه بالخارج ،
هذا جيد
[موسيقى]
أنت